what a start to the year he's had the
tearful press conference in Australia
where he announced he was gonna retire
at Wimbledon then he went out and played
an amazing match then he had a hip
operation and 37 days later here is Andy
Murray and it's fantastic to see how is
the bionic hip yes it's going well so
far I mean I'm in no pay and when I'm
walking around and stuff so you know
that was the the reason for having the
the operation the first blow so I feel
just feel a lot happier in myself on a
daily basis and yeah it feels it feels
pretty good take us back to the table
press conference because you must have
been at a very low point to speak like
that to speak about the end of your
career
I don't think people realize how much
pain you're in what was the thought
process
I mean basically for the last kind of 12
18 months you know as an athlete and
kind of competitor when people ask you
you know how you're getting on at
competitions and stuff you you're not
going to say on my hips terrible because
you might be playing them the next week
or you know I'm trying to be optimistic
when I'm getting asked about my hip and
press conferences and stuff and you know
what I was struggling you know I was
struggling for a long time and you could
see that and just the way I was walking
around in terms of you know limping
everywhere I was going so it was it was
tough and in that press conference
obviously I kind of spoke from my heart
a little bit and kind of opened up and
they had been been tough kind of 18
months so I felt much better after I'd
done it and obviously had the operation
now and I feel good and how's the last
month been as it had been tough the
rehab how'd you feel it's been I mean
rehabs never loads of fun I mean it's
like it's quite quite tedious a little
bit boring and I've done a bunch of
different stints of rehab over the last
18 months so but because I'm seeing
progress now and because I'm not in pain
it's sort of motivating me each day to
be doing it because I'm noticing that
things are getting better and that I
don't have to limp anymore and you know
my hip feels feels good which hadn't
been the case the last 18 months I've
been doing rehab and my hip was still
really sore so you know now I'm seeing
some good signs
yeah positive about the outcome
you couldn't tie your shoelaces before
can you can you do that now I still
can't do that yet but that's more
through stiffness and stuff from the
operation rather than rather than pain
but I'm getting there I can just about
do it still got these slip-on shoes on
just now which which which helped but
I'm getting closer so is the plan to get
back to top level tennis in your mind is
that what you're aiming for that's what
I would like to do if it's possible
because I love tennis and that's what I
want to do but I mean I spoke about that
in Australia a little bit it's not the
reason for having the operation done
it's not you know nobody's done it had
this operation then going back to play
high-level singles before so I can't say
for certain I'll be able to do it the
initial signs are quite good but you
know I wanted to have the operation for
my life like to be pain-free walking
around and doing stuff with my family
and not not not feel like that was a
burden and then it was really painful
doing it so I'm really happy I've had it
done and now I just have to wait and see
how good my my hip will get and I won't
know that for a good good few months you
have a gut feel about it though that you
might be able to play really good tennis
again well like in Australia for example
I obviously I played a really really
good match there against a guy who made
the quarterfinals there owners and the
top twenty in the world and I don't
think my hip will be worse than it was
then because I couldn't straighten my
leg so I was at times felt like I was
almost playing on one leg at times and I
was still able to compete at that level
in that much discomfort so providing you
know the muscles and staff can you know
stabilize my new hip
you know I'm optimistic but you know
that could be completely misplaced you
know I you know as athletes I guess you
always feel like you're going to be able
to come back from stuff and you'll be
okay but I don't really know this time
and you know all of the surgeons you
know that I've spoken to it being very
honest with me about that and we just
kind of have to
so wait and see it's women I'm guessing
woman's gonna be too soon or is it yeah
I mean I don't know but most likely it
would be I mean I think for singles you
know most likely it would be can't say
for sure but doubles I mean Bob Bryan
was back playing at the Australian Open
you know and after five and a half
months or you know Wimbledon comes
pretty much five and a half months after
I'd had my operation and I communicate
with him Bailey about you know stuff and
the rehab that he was doing and things
that worked and didn't and he certainly
feels like he could have done things a
bit better at the beginning of rehab so
you know maybe I can cut a bit of time
off that but yeah I don't know exactly I
really I really can can answer those
questions until I start running around
because it might feel completely
different to me and lots of people have
said that that when they have the
operation some people feel like this a
metal hip in there and some people feel
much better than they did before it just
depends on the individual and I don't
know how that will be yet how just very
quickly will you give it in terms of how
long will I give it until I decide okay
this is how long we give you know a year
half a year yeah this is working so it's
not working I think probably about seven
eight months I think by then I would
know definitively you know this isn't
this is as good as it's going to get
that's kind of the timeframe that I've
kind of set myself in my head if things
aren't going well maybe I know a little
bit sooner than that but you know it's a
big operation and you know it takes time
for muscles and things to heal properly
and for me to get used to moving around
with it and things but yeah I'd say that
would be a fair a fair amount of time
before I'll be able to say definitively
this isn't good enough or this actually
feels great it's better than my hip
before and I can crack on guys I'm
guessing you're pain free so you're
happy with that exactly
much much RP well well as your mom said
if anyone can do it he can